welcome back now that we've hopefully
learned a little bit about newton's laws
let's apply them to to solve some
problems so let's say i have a i don't
know some kind of vehicle a car
motorcycle or something and let's say
its mass
is 500 grams
and let's say that i can accelerate this
vehicle
at an acceleration of i don't know three
[Music]
three
centimeters
per second squared
what's the force that i need to
apply to this mass to accelerate it at
this speed and when we want the answer
in newtons so what's the force
so we're just going to use newton's
second law newton's second law tells us
force
is equal to mass times acceleration so
you might
want to or you might be tempted just to
multiply mass times acceleration you'd
get
you'd get force is equal to let's see
500 grams
times three centimeters per second
squared and you would get
force is equal to 1500
gram
centimeters per second squared
and if you did this you would be right
although your answer would not be
newtons and now you would have to
somehow try to convert
this set of units
to newtons and what are newtons well we
learned in when we did newton's laws
that that a newton so one newton
is equal to one kilogram
meter per second squared so somehow we
have to convert the grams to kilograms
and we have to convert the centimeters
to meters we could do it after the fact
here or what i find it easier to do is
actually to convert
the mass and the acceleration units
first and then just do that f equals ma
so what's 500 grams in kilograms
well 500 grams
is
half
well a kilogram is a thousand grams
right so 500 is going to be half a
kilogram
right
one kilogram is a thousand grams so 0.5
kilograms is 500 grams
similarly
3 centimeters is how many meters
well
1 meter is 300
sorry one meter i'm i think i'm
dehydrated one meter is a hundred
centimeters right so three centimeters
is .03
meters
per second squared
hopefully
this makes sense to you three
centimeters is .03 meters and now we are
ready we have our mass in kilograms and
we have our acceleration in meters per
second squared and if this is confusing
you should you should watch the units
videos because this is all i'm doing i'm
just doing unit conversion so let's go
back to force equals mass times
acceleration
so the force
is equal to 0.5 kilograms
0.5 kilograms
times the acceleration which is 0.03
[Music]
meters per second squared
and this equals what's 0.5 times 0.03
i'll do it down here just because
multiplying decimals seems to be
a problem for a lot of people including
myself many times so what you do you
just multiply the numbers right 5 times
0 3 or 5 times 3 is 15
and then how many points do we have
behind the decimal how many digits
behind the decimal see we have one two
three so one two
three all right we have to add the zero
because we need three
spaces behind the decimal point
so we get the force
is equal to 0.015
kilogram
meters
per second squared
and this is a newton so the force is
equal to .015
newtons
let's do another problem
and this one's going to be and actually
i think you'll find
most of the difficult
newton's laws problems or force problems
they're just some combination of making
sure you get the units right and when
we're talking about in one dimension
it's the difficult part is usually
getting the units right
or
just just the math just the algebra so
if you have trouble with this it's
usually because you have to just brush
up a little bit on the algebra the
physics itself is just force equals mass
times acceleration as we will see in
this problem
so let's say that when i apply some
force
some particular force
i use this little zero here so i call
that force f sub zero so this means a
particular force that this is some value
when i apply
that force to some mass let's call that
ma m sub zero i get some acceleration
i get
acceleration a sub 0. right we could
have put numbers here we could have said
well
if i apply a force of 10 newtons
to a mass of i don't know to a mass of
let's say 2 kilograms
i have an acceleration of 5
meters per second squared but i'm just
doing this because this could be any
relationship and let's say the problem
tells us that when i put another mass
with this first mass so let's say that
you know let me draw this diagram
so here's my mass
m sub zero when i apply a force
of f sub zero to it
i get an acceleration of a sub zero
now the problem tells us when i add
another mass so let's say i stack it up
and we're like in an ice skating rink or
something
and i stack another mass up here and
let's call this mass m1
when i stack another mass on here so let
me redraw it actually down here
because it's a different case
and i apply the same force
so i apply the same force and now i have
this new mass on here i'll do it in
m1
the problem tells us that my new
acceleration is one-fifth the original
acceleration so it's one-fifth of
whatever this was
so it's one-fifth
a sub zero
so the question is
what is the ratio of
m sub 0 to m sub 1. so m sub 0 to m
sub 1 is equal to what
and i'm going to keep it in abstract
variables just to confuse you but and
then i'll show you that you could
actually substitute numbers and and the
problem becomes a little easier and you
might want to pause it and try it for
yourself
so let's work it through so we know we
have this relationship to start off with
and just for
simplicity let's write what m sub 0 is
in in in terms of f and a so we just
divide both sides by a sub 0 and you get
f sub 0 divided by a sub 0 is equal to m
sub 0.
good so let's just put that aside for a
second
and let's do that same relationship here
with this so here this relationship
tells us that f sub zero
is equal to
m one plus m
zero
and
times this new acceleration which is
one-fifth a sub zero
and so if we divide both sides by this
term right here
we get right
dividing by one-fifth is the same thing
as multiplying by five so you get five
f sub zero
over a sub zero is equal to m one plus m
zero right i just divided both sides by
this term right here
well what's f sub 0 what's this let me
switch colors again what's f sub 0
divided by a sub 0
what's here it's what we solved for in
the beginning right we just got it from
this relationship so we could substitute
five times f sub zero divided by a sub
zero is the same thing as five times m
zero so we draw a line here so we have a
new relationship five m zero is equal to
m one plus m zero all i did is i
substituted this for this
or this for that and i used this
relationship which we got in the
beginning to do that
and now what do we have we have five m
sub zero is equal to m one plus m0 we
could subtract m0 from both sides
and you get 4
m0 is equal to m1
you could divide both sides or you could
divide both sides by m0 and you get 4
is equal to m 1 over m
and you can invert this relationship and
you can get m
0 over m sub 1 is equal to 1 4. so what
we learned is the ratio of the old mass
to the new mass
is one to four and that's the problem
and actually i will leave it for you as
an exercise to figure out to just do the
same problem using the numbers
actually let's let's just i will do that
actually in the next video just to show
you that that actually would have been a
simple way to do it but some it's good
to get used to this just so you get you
can solve things in general terms i'll
see in the next video